We can start addressing these kind of
issues by practicing adaptive design.
Let's start by talking about
the when of adaptive design.
Or, at what points do you want
to begin adapting your UI?
The basic idea of adaptive design
is that you change your UI,
based on the screen size.
That is, your UI adapts to
the amount of horizontal or
vertical space that you have.
We do this by introducing
what we call break points.
Break points are the points
at which your UI changes.
For example, you could show another
column of content once your screen width
is 600 dp or larger.
600 dp is therefore
a break point in your UI.
Now you might be wondering,
how should I choose these break points?
Well, the material spec identifies
some common breakpoints.
While you can start with these,
it's important to ensure your
breakpoints make sense for your content.
It's important to think content first.
You can then think of the breakpoints
as the point in which your UI
literally breaks for
the content it's trying to present.
So what does it mean
to be content versed?
In this case, it means starting by
figuring out what the constraints
are for your content, and then figuring
out the break points from there.
Let's return to some of the layouts
we looked at in lesson one and
see how they might
work on larger devices.
Now, as the screen width
increases with this layout
The line length the text increases
is making harder to read.
So, you might want to have
a break point somewhere
where the line length exceeds
45 to 75 character guideline.
In this form layout,
on wider devices there's too much
unused space, here on the right.
Making it feel unbalanced.
You might set a break point round about
say here to re balance the layout.
In this example,
see how these two buttons take
up half the width of the screen.
On wider layouts,
this starts to get quite awkward,
around about say this point.
So that might be a break point.
Also notice how maintaining
a constant height and
center crop image starts to
break down on larger sizes.
It ends up showing this kind of small
sliver of the whole image greatly
blown up.
Lastly, the left-align
content can start to feel
unbalanced leaving large empty
areas on the right of the screen.
Choosing break points based
on content requirements
is more future proof than basing
them on a specific set of devices.
You'll know those requirements
will be satisfied no matter
what devices get thrown your way.
Okay.
So
now that we know that we want to do
something different when a UI gets to
these break point sizes,
in the next section we'll talk
about how you do this with code.